farmer Brad here and I'm out in the high
tunnel trying to get some work done on
clearing got out here in the high tunnel
to help me so out here I ended up
putting the chicken tikka and the other
side had some vegetation growing aka
weeds and this seems like it will be
okay so I've also been trying to work
all the brush down that way and I don't
know if I'm gonna mess with with
landscape fabric just partly because I
want to be able to continually add
manure and things to it and really once
you put down landscape fabric you're
basically committed to that I also have
a couple more holes that I need to fix
in the roof there's one over here and
then there's one run along there and I'm
debating whether or not to just frame
out this side it's a frame out this side
for the door and just keep it solid
since this is where most of the wind
comes from and let me show you over here
over here is where I plan to put the
water sprinkler system right there so
the idea is that the water tank would be
outside of there the water would come in
here and I think I would may just attach
the pipe along there on the inside but
I'm also thinking about putting
electrical long there because I have to
get the electrical all the way over to
there to power the solenoids that I'll
be using for
watering the drip tape and then the
other concern that I have is since this
plastic up here has a hole can I really
seal that off enough because what I was
going to do is put my electrical panel
in here from the solar so in the
comments if you can leave me any
suggestions what I'm what I'm
envisioning is I have a uniball you know
strut or that I'll span between here and
then I'll be able to put like a piece of
plywood in order to keep basically to be
able to mount stuff to and then that's
where the power panel will be and then
I'll store the batteries below right now
I just have one battery and this is kind
of where the solar would come in part of
the reason for that is I plan on putting
the solar just out this way and I don't
want to have to put it out too far but
if you look at these three trees there
I'm worried that those are gonna block
the Sun from the solar panels so what
I'm thinking about doing is cutting that
was about five feet off the ground level
and then I'll take the straighter part
of the top and make raised garden beds
out of that and then those three tree
stumps I might be able to make like a
kid's treehouse platform out of it well
that's at least the thought and I have
my littlest helper out here she's having
fun roaming around
and then here's the Kubota tractor it's
done majority of the difficult projects
here on the farm and then I got the
trailer and the generator and then I I
take that generator most places and it
ends up powering a chainsaw another
thing that I'm thinking about doing is
sort of flattening out this and putting
a 450 gallon water tank on there that
then I could put a gutter off the side
of this and have it collect rainwater
and then use that rainwater to water the
chickens in the pasture and that would
just be a way of saving me from having a
cart
fresh water back here so those are some
thoughts I think I'm gonna get some
concrete tubes or cardboard tubes sort
of build a foundation of where those pet
those feet on the tower would go and
then I would be able to get that secured
to the ground and then get the IBC tote
up on top of there and then I can have
that water tank taken care of
so I just wanted to hop on and show you
what I've been doing in the high tunnel
I still have a lot of work before I'm
able to plant and stuff I also have some
compost that I'm going to add and I'm
gonna add the brooder pine chips to help
as a fertilizer as well for the ground
but yeah so thanks for watching and have
a good night